all right cool cool cool and we go
live all right citizens of the reject
Nation you know what to do as always let
us know if we are live my friends it is
Coy and I today uh we got a lot to talk
about um but before we you know hop into
everything and and start breaking things
down here and start you know kind of
chewing the bones and whatnot just let
us know that y'all are here let us know
that you can see and hear us because uh
otherwise we'll just be talking into the
void uh which you know is fun but uh you
know it's it's not good entertainment
for the rest of you guys so uh so yeah
live I see it Jonathan Davidson
wonderful uh nerdy wave Chay Jamari
Middleton TS Funk 2005 uh awesome to see
you all here I wish we were talking on a
more you know upbeat circumstance um but
yeah before we hop into this got to you
know just let you guys know a couple of
things um first of all uh uh you know
just a disclaimer for YouTube and for
everybody in here viewing uh in the
discussion that we have today um we are
you know we're providing an objective
report on the details that are out and
you know probably a little bit of
speculation based on that we are not
experts um but we have been following
along to a degree um so that yeah uh
while our conversation today may involve
mature themes and sensitive subjects and
controversial topics uh we are committed
to presenting this information
responsibly and uh we are not going to
show any explicit footage chances are
you guys have already seen most of that
stuff and at no point are we going to
endorse or promote hate or violence no
matter whose side you maybe find
yourself on in this conflict um and yeah
our aim is basically just to go over the
details in an informative and hopefully
maybe somewhat educational way and uh
yeah we'll be adhering to YouTube's
Community guidelines and ensuring a
respectful environment for all you guys
um so yeah it's me and koi today uh due
to the schedule we we're just you know
it's the holidays things are getting
crazy over here we have a lot to get
done before Christmas so because a
certain company decided to give us uh
screenings for episodes uh the day
before Christmas Eve so that's nice what
who could who could possibly that Bey I
don't know who you're talking about we
all want to work up until the wire we
appreciate it so but yeah normally this
would be like a 10 to 15 minute video uh
but today uh we are yeah we're here live
because there's less editing and stuff
involved overall um yeah we obviously as
well don't know as much as the jury
knows we haven't been privy to
everything that they had to deliberate
over um but we're going to again do our
best to be you know objective and you
know straight with the facts that are
available to us um yeah we don't you
know talk about celebrity trials much
here on this channel we're not a big
gossip Channel but since this this is
you know it's Kang it's a big big part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe they
have you know rested so much on Jonathan
major so yeah it makes we we felt remiss
if we didn't at least address this
because you know people were going to be
wondering how this will affect you know
the film industry the thing we do talk
about uh and Marvel in particular which
we talk about a lot and uh just in case
you're wondering Greg is not here today
because uh he and his lovely wife are
celebrating their anniversary of their
wedding um so yeah uh you know it's been
a year they deserve a little bit of a
rest a little bit of a break this news
broke today and uh and yeah he still
worked he put together a thumbnail put
together thumbnail and and wrangled our
you know he did all the calls he he
wrangled us kids he's now he's done he's
sitting yeah so uh yeah and and he's I
mean what really is happening is he's
avoiding having to he's going out for
drinks with you know the rest of the
reject Nation he just doesn't want to do
this bending over backwards
he's out there enjoying the pub yeah he
just doesn't want to be you know part of
you know a touchy subject discussion
today um but yeah so we're going to get
into this uh obviously there's a lot to
talk about and we want to hear your guys
thoughts as well um so let's go into the
main view look at that whoa hey that's
us we're uh in the little tiny box um
but yeah how's it going guys let us know
first and foremost what you think of the
verdict and and of the
you know evidence that you've seen or
the details that you have heard um from
my understanding today out of four
charges um which you know um the four
charges were assault aggravated
harassment and direct harassment uh
stemming from the 911 call made on March
25th regarding uh Grace Jabari uh he
pleaded not guilty to all charges and uh
Jabari alleged that Majors caused her
injuries during an altercation in a car
there's no footage from inside the car
we've seen some footage from outside the
car um but it's my understanding that
today uh Jonathan majers was found
guilty of assault in the third degree uh
essentially
recklessly uh uh recklessly causing
physical injury uh but not necessarily
with intent and then uh harassment in
the second degree he was found not
guilty of assault in the third degree
with intent to cause injury uh so it
seems to me the intent was the
separation between the the charges I'm
not a lawyer between the charges that
actually uh we found guilty versus not
guilty is what I I gathered yeah
absolutely so you know the big question
here then becomes yeah the intent uh the
you know premeditated nature of you know
the actions on trial here um and I don't
know I mean I guess before we hop into
the nitty-gritty what's your feeling on
this I mean do you have a general just
gut sense or or assessment uh I think I
think it's really hard because there's
no version
um there's no reality where we know all
the facts and it's really a trial
difficult thing to assess that and
that's why I think the deliberation went
for five hours um because it's always
these trials are always really messy
with one side trying to make the other
look as bad as possible and that's like
the nature of how you do trials uh is
you try to make someone you defame
someone's character as far as possible
and then you go back and forth and I
think this is a no- win scenario um
because now we basically get uh a woman
who who will always be known as this and
a man who will always be known as this
and regardless of either of their other
talents this is just all of the the
details that we'd never have uh
otherwise so I'm glad that it doesn't
seem like the premeditated element um
was seen as guilty it doesn't seem like
this was something that was
uh a thing that wanted anyone wanted to
happen um it does seem like you know
violence did occur um I don't think I
see a lot I mean the internet's a gross
gross place I'm pretty what do you mean
uh but the fact that you have you know
people just immediately on one side
saying well of course he did it and
people on the other side saying uh of
course he didn't do it because there's
footage of him running away from her we
don't know anything um so on one side
there is the audio of him basically
comparing her to these you know these
really strong powerful women that was
definitely manipulated aggressively to
people like making fun of him for it and
yes it's a silly thing to say uh he was
basically you know saying like I'm a
great man I want a great woman behind me
and then that turned into like people
turning him into the a monster about a
statement that wasn't necessarily true
but again you try to defame someone as
far as possible then you've got the
footage from running away so everyone
assumes like well he couldn't have done
anything wrong why would he be running
but we don't know if you know he's
trying to get away from the situation
because he realized he did something
wrong we don't know and we can never
know so this long rant to basically say
what I'm glad of is that he doesn't seem
to be someone who premeditated attacked
her it was something that happened in
the throws of a heated argument and that
is what he's been charged with is
something happening in that moment what
I don't love is that you know it seems
to be um an actual act of violence like
this is someone who I really respect as
an actor who who I you know enjoyed the
work of quite a bit so it's always
shitty to find out you know someone you
respect and admire uh is capable of
something that has apparently occurred
yeah and and I mean people in the chat
are are sounding off right now basically
saying that Marvel has now officially
fired him I'm pulling that up just to
verify um but yeah I mean I I certainly
believe that that I mean would be the
next yeah I mean discussing film has it
uh roll oh yep Marvel yeah Rolling
Stones reporting it um deadline yeah uh
I wonder if there's a particular
statement but I mean I guess you could
have seen you certainly would have seen
that coming at the very least at least
um and yeah I mean this whole thing to
me has seemed like a a pretty messy
situation
because in a different way this almost
reminds me of what happened with Johnny
Depp and Amber herd in the sense that
there's
clearly I don't know there's so much
really strong opinionation on both sides
of the evidence and obviously all of us
out here the the the Johnny Depp trial
was was majorly you know publicized and
we got so many glimpses into that and
there was video and all that stuff but
what seemed to be happening there was
you know regardless of which side you a
lot more of the blame to you have a
situation where it seems like two people
are in a toxic situation that isn't good
for the either of them and that's kind
of this just a subjective opinion but
that's kind of the vibe that I have
gotten from this thus far because it
doesn't really all of the evidence I've
heard hasn't really made anybody seem
particularly great or shun a light of
you know innocence directly on anybody
and I mean I do at least you know again
we're just two people at home keeping up
with the news or whatever but it does
only reporting on it because of the
people that would ask over and over
again I'm not thrilled about this no
this not where I want to be no I mean I
haven't been sitting here rooting for
you know find him guilty or whatever um
I didn't touch the major I mean you
bring up uh Depp and Amber herd I I
intentionally never say anything about
that cuz I think they're both really
shitty towards each other in this case
pun intended uh but I don't think um
unless this related to what we do cover
on the channel it's it's any of our
business but this is affecting the
business that we do discuss yeah um but
I do think that uh people want to
villainize people I think people get
very excited to feel better than other
people so they like to kick people while
they're down so I think that the the
Depp herd uh instance is a great example
of people celebrating awful and um
I think think it's gross yeah yeah and I
mean you know I find it interesting that
there are still a lot of people out
there who are you know completely on the
side of like oh no he's he's completely
innocent he's framed and and and yeah I
mean there's a lot of evidence that is
kind of strange and hinky that does
support some of his side of the story um
but to me just given all the different
messages that we've seen uh you know
leaked out and whatnot and the attitudes
on display it certainly seems like there
is some level of toxicity and narcissism
at work here some people in the chat
have brought up um you know some of the
abusive behaviors that he has
demonstrated in maybe a controlling
fashion or whatever again through some
of these M the text messages were pretty
uh awful to read pretty harsh and and
yeah and and I mean not going to get
into all the nitty-gritty details but
certainly there seemed like a bit of a
back and forth in terms of
codependency threats of certain kinds of
harm uh that are not the obvious kinds
um and and yeah this seems like a pretty
harsh situation all around to me and I
can kind of imagine I mean it took what
was it it was six jurors after four
hours of deliberation over three days a
six-person jury reached a verdict in the
trial um he was accompanied by his
attorneys and supported by his now
girlfriend Megan good family members
found guilty of uh two of the charges
and acquitted of two others um so we
have till February the 6th to if he will
uh you know be sentenced to jail time
which could be up to one year um but
yeah this this whole thing has really
been kind of harsh and ugly to follow
because again I do think that there is a
bit of zealousness to pull one of your
favorite words in basically taking any
hole in the prosecution side as just
proof of complete innocence and I think
that's the tricky and and
difficult part of any one of these types
of situations is the fact that to
me I'm sitting here yeah just it's it's
as I said before to me this seems like a
toxic ugly situation these two people
maybe shouldn't have been together I'm
sure there were things that Drew them
together but you know here where We've
Ended up it seems like it's brought
certain aspects of this person's
character to light and there have been
other people and again it's all heay we
don't know there have been other people
who have corroborated at least some of
these manipulative and
trolling uh behaviors from Majors um but
yeah the whole thing I I would agree is
is disappointing because I mean yeah
it's been really fun and enjoyable to
watch his Star Rise he's a terrific
actor most certainly I'm very curious to
see what happens after this um because
again you know it's uh he's going to be
let go of Marvel at the very least but I
wonder with this amount of you know
doubt in the court of public opinion
whether or not
uh you know he will be just completely
shunned from Hollywood or whether in a
couple years he'll start popping up in
certain things again all uh any number
of people who have been canell out of
society um and I mean that's a good
question uh s s's guitar I hope I said
your name right just will like I'll put
it to you guys in the chat you know
after all this is said and done if he
serves whatever time is allotted him you
know would you be back out there
searching out his performances and
looking to support his movies or are you
kind of yeah are you sort of done with
them uh from now on and uh and yes Larry
Reid I'm glad you're in here for the
real important questions Rebel Moon uh
we we'll have some thoughts on Rebel
moon in a few days don't even worry um
and and I'm curious too because I've
heard it said and I don't know if this
is true but I've heard it said that the
Marvel contract
involved a scenario in which only Majors
could play Kang but at the same time now
I'm like if this is if there's a legal
cause for dissolution would they have to
stick to that or or anything um because
yeah at least uh at least as of deadline
a studio rep has confirmed that they are
not going to move forward with Majors so
do we get a whole new Kang or do we do
the you know rumored switch over to a Dr
Doom or something like that I think no
matter what this kind of establishes
Secret Wars will probably clean up
continuity in a stronger way than it
might have originally I think they're
already calling uh King Dynasty Avengers
5 um I think basically it's going to be
I mean I think it was always gonna kind
of be Avengers versus the X-Men I think
now it's going to be Avengers versus the
X-Men in a very different way like a
bigger way um I think Deadpool you know
is is not done shooting and it might
tweak the third act a bit as it goes
into Secret Wars we always knew that
Deadpool was going to go directly into
Secret Wars I think now it's going to
move certain things up I think uh Doom
was always going to be the one who took
over the king the idea was was always to
me obviously that it was going to be
Kang being a whole phase of big bad that
Doom easily usurps and thus making Doom
such a powerful villain that you're like
oh my God he took out the big bad um but
now I just assume that's going to be a
little earlier uh I don't think they
will recast Kang necessarily um I think
Marvel's in a really tricky spot because
you know Daniel Daniel Destin keton uh
no Destin Daniel Daniel the d uh I
think is uh is off of of Kang Dynasty
which is now Avengers 5 but he is doing
shangi too but you've even got things
like you know simu having uh you know
Achilles surgery like the Marvel
Universe has been in a really tricky
spot because their number one martial
artist got literally Achilles and then
you got you know this horrible situation
we've got so many things um that have up
the 10year plan so I think they're going
to how is that spin I'm giving facts I
don't understand people cheering for
anything in this in this there's no good
here yeah and it's interesting to look
in the chat I mean I I feel like we
typically have a pretty positive uh
comment section here but I do see a lot
of you know direct support
for for Jonathan Majors but moreover uh
some mock like if if we can discourage
one thing I don't want to you know come
in and Mom you guys but let's at least
be respectful even if you don't see any
of the validity of uh of uh what's her
name Grace Jabari if you don't see any
side of her story you know everyone's
perspective is their own but let's at
least be respectful in here and let's
not fly off on I saw one comment like oh
you can't be a victim and a strong woman
at the same time and there's only two
kinds yes you can and uh this whole
thing is pretty ugly and I would at
least encourage you guys to entertain
the idea that we wouldn't be in this
situation completely flippantly or or at
least that's what I hope and I guess
anything can happen but uh let's at
least be respectful of the moment um and
yeah regardless of whether you think
Majors belongs in jail or whether you
think he's completely innocent let's at
least uh let's keep it above the level
here in the chat if you want to go off
on some other message board and uh and
talk some there are plenty of
people making plenty of videos that are
all of the innan commentary you want
there are people making people bought
houses off of the Johnny Depp Amber herd
trial there are plenty of people on
YouTube go there it's waiting for you
people are profiting off this enjoy
those people find your gross little
pockets but not here CU that's not what
we're doing we're giving news about a
situation that sucks for everyone and
we're talking about how that's going to
affect the thing we do talk about in
this channel which is movies this is the
real rejects this isn't the gossip
Channel this isn't TMZ this isn't we're
not we're trying not to be culture
vultures this is the absolute last thing
I wanted to do with my Monday I don't
need to read your Dil it's okay I mean
and and and big love and respect to the
guys in here to all the of you guys in
here who are you know keeping it above
the level and and you know being
respectful at the very least um and I
mean yeah if we're going to sit in here
and be like ah you know it's the big the
big looming ghoul of
feminism go home like there's a lot more
complication to life than simply that
and I feel like if this was a complete
flippant thing they wouldn't have spent
as much time as they have uh you know
they wouldn't have spent as much time as
they have corroborating things and you
know the the jury that they got had to
deliberate quite a bit from what I
understand and you know took a good
amount of extra time in reviewing the
facts of the case obviously they have
more facts than we do uh so yeah I don't
care about your opinion and uh Eddie
Tucker you don't matter to me uh right
now he has been found guilty of uh
assault in the third degree and
harassment in the second degree um so
that and to clarify once again that's
assault without um uh it's assault
causing Reckless uh injury but not with
the intent to cause injury the ones he
was found not guilty of was the assault
in the third degree with intent and uh
and another aggravated harassment uh
charge so I mean the situation that that
happened in this taxi truck whatever it
is certainly seems like the most d
dubious uh because yeah we'll just never
see inside that car we've had the the
driver's accounts to deal with and then
you know beyond that we have you know
surveillance videos from the street um
but yeah this whole thing is is is I I
would say nuanced and uh it would at
least be good to and I think that's why
the trial went the way it did like I
think the reason that it didn't get all
four charges is because it's nuanced I
think the reason that it wasn't
completely innocent is because there are
both sides being to a point at fault but
again like I said at the top this is two
people trying to make the other look as
bad as possible because that's the way
trials are done yeah and I mean again at
least from where I'm sitting it doesn't
seem like anybody is completely innocent
here and I know that from the accounts
and from again certain conversations we
have been PR to you know Jonathan
Major's uh he's clearly got the means to
defend his status and his reputation and
whatnot and uh I don't know some of
these backs and forths like yeah
especially that one that's been sort of
twisted around of him talking about all
the you know sort of famous figures that
he aspires to be like you know I detect
a hint of narcissism there but maybe not
I mean you got to aim high but I can
also see how this might be a person who
isn't completely aware of you know the
use of his own power and status and
whatnot um and I don't know I mean here
we can go into some more of the facts
here testimonials and allegations uh
during the first four days of trial
Jabari testified uh testified that
Majors injured her while attempting to
snatch his phone after seeing a text
message allegedly perhaps from some
other woman um you know and the charges
here directly relate to this alleged
incident in the car so I mean there's
been a lot of other stuff brought to
light and I know that there's debate
about uh what kind of character-based
evidence is admissible and or you know
should be taken seriously in a case like
this um on the defense and prosecution
strategy side um you know the defense
argued that Majors was preventing Jabari
from running into traffic while the
prosecution approached the case as you
know your more straight domestic
violence situation uh the defense
question jaar's credibility suggested
she was seeking Revenge which you know
is well documented especially on message
boards and whatnot um and uh John boa
Tori got brought into the convo and
people started talking about recasting
Kang um yeah I've seen youra I've seen
Tron boa I was saying y'd be great but I
think he still happening oh I mean he
can be both you know why not I mean what
if the character is a variant of G yeah
uh and and I mean you know it's uh I
mean yeah and people are saying there's
there's a a literally video of him
hurting her at some point which I have
I've seen the video of him running away
from you know down the down many blocks
cre through training at work which I
mean yeah that that whole thing seemed
like sort of we're in the midst of some
kind of heated altercation and and I
just want to get out of this but again
that's that's a thing we don't know
details of right if you've got someone
running away from something it could be
like I just messed up and I realize it
I'm running away or it could be she's
going to do something to me I need to
run away we weren't there and that's
what I think is so messy about releasing
that footage and of course it's TMZ and
people like that that do it because they
want this conversation yeah and uh I
mean you know from the the prosecution
side jabari's attorney Ross Kramer has
expressed satisfaction with the verdict
and highlighted jabari's courage uh the
statement hoped uh the verdict would
Inspire other victims of assault to come
forward and I mean this is one of the
trickiest things to parse in terms of
the law you know is is these kinds of
situations because so much does come
down to he said she said situations that
are only going to be described and
nobody has direct account for other than
the people involved um so I guess on
that note I would encourage y'all in the
chat to at least you know be
conscientious with your level of
commitment to whatever side of this that
you have committed to because I just I
think it's probably full hearty to
assume that just any one of us Rando
normal people knows intimately what has
been going on and absolutely Amanda Jay
Washington for Kang all
day um so yeah uh trial observations
Majors uh who attended every day of the
two-e trial did not testify um and
remain you know mostly St IC emotionless
except for during the uh closing
arguments closing statements um and the
defense argued that you know Jabari was
the aggressor and suggested that she
injured herself after Revenge partying
there are those videos out of her after
the alleged incident you know in in a
bar of some kind um evidence included
surveillance footage and photos um you
know the prosecution's evidence uh
introduced texts and recordings between
the two of them alleging a pattern of
abuse uh the evidence was intended to
show Major's character and potential for
committing the alleged crimes and and I
mean that's the thing about this case
for me and yes I believe the writer
strike and the actor strike are both
over uh they have voted right
likeii we are up until two and a half
years from now we're we're we're working
so everyone's back to work everyone's
good um and this is the longest like I
think into of the holidays we've worked
because of it I think we're going come
back quicker like usually La shuts down
for like two weeks yeah yeah uh and so
yeah I mean that's that's a thing for me
this this this last bit that we just
read you know the the evidence that they
introduced you know intended to show a
potential for you know the capability of
committing these uh acts and whatnot and
I mean that's that's the thing I don't
know exactly none of us do what happened
that day but it does seem like the
potential for this to be a toxic
relationship was there and uh and
certain of those behaviors while maybe
not all illegal certainly don't ring
very well um I don't know that that has
been a lot of my inspiration to kind of
keep uh an arms length from any
solid I don't know from choosing a side
too heavily yeah yeah yeah um because
again it's it's like there's a lot of
and and from what I've heard about the
actual proceedings uh beyond the
information that we know you know
there's certainly uh strange and hinky
details regarding Jabari story there are
strange and hinky details regarding
major story um and yeah the I got to
feel like some tangible thing exists in
the middle of that even if it's not
exactly what we're seeing or hearing at
the moment there where there's I
hesitate to say but where there's smoke
there could be fire um and in the
Manhattan da statement uh the district
attorney Al Alvin Bragg emphasized the
trials focus on Survivor centered
Justice and the pattern of abuse and
coercion identified in Major's case and
I mean that's something again looking at
some of those text messages about like
oh you know don't worry I'm not going to
tell people uh you know about what
really happened or whatever or you know
oh I I'm going to downplay whatever this
you know injury was and whatnot like
those those things certainly read like
codependency and not wanting to anger
somebody that you might be a bit afraid
of um and I mean hey I mean and and
people are saying like you know I mean
this isn't to say I mean again I brought
up Johnny Depp and Amber herd partly
because um you know this this guy says
she was clearly grabbing him and she
even took his phone and hit him with it
and wouldn't let him leave I don't know
and that's the thing is I I brought up
Johnny Depp and Amber herd partly
because that situation certainly seemed
to me given everything like even if you
have your opinions about who is more of
the innocent or the aggressor in that
situation it seems like abuses happened
back and forth I either way so uh you
know you can be in a situation where
yeah maybe she was attacking him that
particular day but it also seems like
there's more to it than just Jonathan
major has a severely abusive girlfriend
you know what I mean uh no I'm not
trying to victim blame at all I'm just
trying to say that we are not there for
all the details and certainly I am the
kind of person if you want like a uh you
know transparency I am the kind of
person who yeah is more inclined to side
with a Survivor uh you know somebody in
jabari's position certainly however
again you look at the am again like
looking at the Amber herd trial that's
somebody who at first I might have been
inclined to be like well I'm I until her
account is proven otherwise I I'm kind
of suspect of the other side but also
that went to show us that two people and
and what the thing is life isn't cut dry
two people can have abuses toward each
other and you and I are both like Johnny
Depp fans like we both I mean like
Hunter Thompson era Johnny Depp is is
like so formative to my movie going
experience and Hunter's absolutely a
literary hero of mine but I think it's
important to look past the hero on
screen and look at the evidence as best
you can and again that's what's hard
about this is asking 70% of the chat
what they think is uh they make
decisions not based off any Act actual
evidence because we don't have enough
evidence you have to go with what you do
have um which wasn't much obviously you
know it does look like there was
violence and that is what you have to
look at not at how you perceive the
person and if she said uh that he never
attacked her before this incident in
court then that's good to know I mean
being attacked at any point is probably
not good um but yeah I don't know I mean
clearly we're not all going to agree in
this chat but uh you know
I appreciate y'all weighing in at the
very least and we do have a couple of
super chats let's jump over there real
quick and uh see what y'all have to
say in there um isn't this just the most
fun way to start the week it wasn't
gre's anniversary and he didn't ask me
dude there's no way this is like the DMV
this is just the wor I why dude like I
love you I love you Coy and I love I
love the DMV 10 to 12% of people here I
love the DMV well let's jump into uh uh
the direct thoughts of y'all the peeps
and let's enlarge this window so it's
the right size there we
go alrighty alrighty all right thank you
guys again for showing up and for yeah
and for contributing and just you know
for uh airing out your thoughts and
bearing with us as we talk about this
awkward difficult weird situation that
none of us civilians are actually
qualified to be commenting on um but
yeah uh let's see somebody asked why do
you guys think this happens at the
height of someone's career well I I mean
that's in a lot of General situations I
would just say that for some people it's
really hard to watch somebody who may
have caused you this distress and pain
rise to the top and be hoisted onto a
platform and be celebrated and adored by
so many people um you know I don't know
there's so much made about the time in
which things get reported and uh it's
one of the most unique and horrific
kinds of experiences you can report to
anybody and share with people so to be
uh a as transparent as possible I think
on one side it's someone hoping that the
reach um will get actual awareness
brought to something if that's the case
whether that's them being duplicitous or
them being like I need to get out of
this so I need to make it public because
something horrible happened either one
of those things or it's because
uh there's a lot of pressure when you're
doing well like there's a lot of
pressure when you're doing 18 hour days
and you're having to do all of this
press and you're running around and
maybe that's when you snap so either
it's because of someone thinking this is
the best time to get Awareness on
something or it's something to deal with
someone's mental state uh because of
pressure it it kind of makes sense to
happen at the height of something for a
lot of reasons uh pressure makes
diamonds but also makes explosions um so
it makes sense especially if you're yeah
I mean if you are living
some kind of life in which you are
trying to conceal and or Crush down or
maybe you're not even fully aware of
your behavior yeah like when you're at
the Pinnacle and you have all these
opportunities like that's a stressful
life that's a lot going on like you said
but also people get sloppy people slip
up all sorts of things can happen and I
mean the more you have to lose I got to
imagine uh you know the more tense and
and sort of I don't know I think that
can do things to your mindset you know
when you have so many things to manage
and youve got a status and you have you
know risen to such a place you know I
think people are often fearful of losing
that obviously um but yeah uh there's a
lot of uh interesting chatter going on
in the chat but let's see what the
supers have to say Stefan thank you for
joining us thank you for uh sharing your
thoughts on the funnest day of the year
uh hey guys I listen to the live stream
playbacks on my night shifts oh that's
awesome uh thank you John Coy and Greg
for everything you do love you all and
Happy Holidays love you and and uh
that's amazing yeah I mean you know we
got our podcast that we listen to on
late nights and if we can do that for
any and all any of you guys I mean
that's uh makes me happy hopefully
they're more fun than this normally and
I appreciate that I glad we can get you
through your shifts you're here for this
one
real yeah don't worry next next shift
will be much nicer uh Isaiah Maas I hope
Marvel Studios and thank you for
contributing especially again this isn't
the most like a beat uh you know reason
to jump in the chat but uh I very much
uh appreciate uh you chiming in I hope
Marvel Studios simply has Jonathan major
State a public apology and have him
remain as king since he is found guilty
of two unintentional charges um and I
mean I'm very curious to see what
becomes of this if he does do jail time
because yeah I mean at least again as of
the verdict they convicted him only of
the you know non Premed ated versions of
this I mean which is its own kind of
trouble you know arguably
idea everybody should have enough
self-control uh you know to try and you
know not find yourself in a situation
like this um but you know everybody's
different I don't foresee this happening
quite honestly because again the details
of the case are so heavily debated and
this is just going to follow him for the
time being anyway and the trouble is
that his star I think
Rose in a way that when he was announced
um you know as Kang I feel like
that's people had seen Lovecraft country
people had been buzzing about this guy
but when he became Kang I have to think
that that's when most of the the broad
swath of the populace kind of found out
who this guy is and you know having him
uh yeah like having uh this person tied
so specifically to this brand this
universe this character I feel like it
would be hard to go about it this way
doing you know some kind of apology and
then you know letting him continue on I
don't know if this necessarily means
that his acting career is over after
whatever time gets served or after
whatever I don't think he'll serve time
because of the the charges that actually
were guilty I I honestly think maybe
probation personally uh I don't know I'm
not a lawyer but I I don't I don't I
mean obviously Marvel's already fired
him but he hadn't at this point this is
like our second Super Chat so this was
not through yet but um he doesn't work
for Marvel anymore that said with these
charges I I don't think uh personally I
don't think it'd be jail time we'll see
yeah yeah I would be I guess somewhat
surprised uh but yeah I feel like it's
probably going to be kind of starting
from scratch and and who knows what kind
of Public Image rehab he's going to have
to do because too with Marvel and
everything I mean he has you know
searchs and Le been the subject of just
more and more and more of those kinds of
you know fun interviews and like oh
here's 10 Things I can't live with that
you know like his his uh star has risen
but also just his you know status as a
public Personality yeah his own his own
personality and and
I I it's a it's always hard again when
someone that you respect in both the
public Persona and character Persona
like I really enjoyed Jonathan Major's
interviews I really enjoyed his
worldview his perspective all those
things and that definitely colored my
experience of the trials but as someone
who has the responsibility of knowing
that people are listening to my opinion
whether they're immediately judging it
or not I'm aware that my experience of
Jonathan major made me want this to be
innocent and that's why it's so hard
because you come with all of your
preconceived notions of what this person
is that you have to hope the judge and
jury are capable of separating that how
much exposure they have to him like not
most people we're on a movie chat right
now if you're in here you are on a movie
chat most people the average person
especially probably in a jury has not
watched hours of someone's interviews um
so it's really hard when you do care
about this actor if you care about their
talent you care about their work to have
any sort of removal of that when judging
a a legal situation so um it is a mess
uh and I don't think the the charges
will turn to jail time but I do think
this is obviously a giant shift in
public perception that Marvel is dancing
now yeah and everybody in the chat has
also been asking about what about Ezra
Miller which is always a fair point um
yeah I mean Ezra Miller certainly should
have been dealt with in a different way
than they were uh not I don't know it's
weird because it's like Ezra Miller has
way more alleged you know crimes under
their belt and N none
of yeah I don't know there's no real
real good reason why you know Ezra
Miller should remain and you know Majors
should not or whatever you know but
Ezra's not still flash I think that I
don't know if people are assuming that
he is like that's not a I I I think that
I don't know um it it is both two really
messy public trials but other than that
I don't know um where things landed with
the Ezra Miller trial like I don't know
where they are with all of that right
now so it's not really I don't know I I
don't have enough
gotcha yeah yeah and no more no more
flash for Ezra and and two I I do think
it's that thing of like all these I
think there is a hypocrisy I guess in
the court of public opinion and the way
it interacts with business because if
you look at the rrap sheet of alleged
crimes from Ezra Miller uh some of them
border on this territory but there's
nothing as cut and dry as like oh you
know you're you're this kind of abuser I
feel like it would have been much more
Swift in that sense if that had been the
case um again trying to trying to dance
around some of these more sensitive
issues for because YouTube is is
sensitive um but yeah MC uh no light
um MC no light uh I'm sorry but this is
pure
uh appreciate your opinion
appreciate you jumping in uh I I mean
you know I won't say that there's
nothing can be debated about this but uh
you
know I don't know I don't know if I
would say but but you know to
each their own I suppose coiler hair
thank you for chiming in on the chat uh
the text telling her don't go to the
hospital uh due to the fact that he
can't come to uh what she says sealed
his
fate uh I mean if I'm reading this this
correctly uh I mean sure that's not
really a good look if you're you know
that Max of trying to control the
situation yourself and that sort of
leads you to think that oh maybe there
is some kind of yeah guilt at hand um I
I do think the
um the making it seem like a pattern not
a single incident was what made this a
different trial I I think the incident
in the car is obviously what this trial
was about but the text from months
earlier um basically saying you know
don't don't go to the hospital they'll
ask too many
questions shows some level of repeat um
problem so it's it's not
uh I I again everyone on both sides of
this seems like it's been a real mess I
don't know I wasn't there same I was
there just kidding I know all this stuff
masar is if they fire thank you by the
way uh if they fire Jonathan Majors then
surely they will just keep Kang and have
a variant that doesn't look like Majors
I'm very curious I don't know the exact
details of the contract I have heard it
said once
that he had some kind of stipulation in
there that only he could play King and
I've had I've been curious about that
this whole time because there obviously
have been certain characters in the MCU
in the Multiverse that we have seen
portrayed by multiple actors Loki
certainly being one of them um again I
don't know if some kind of intervening
legal circumstance like this kind of uh
renders that null and void because you
know I guess I would imagine and I'm not
a contract law expert but I would
imagine that you know part of any
contract rides on you being in good
standing with the law um but yeah you
know uh I don't know I I I mean
certainly that seems like the easiest
thing to do and and like the Multiverse
would give you an easy out in that sense
I don't know if it even makes sense um
to be honest the way the way they're
navigating the MCU now is lots of damage
control like if you look at what they're
doing with Captain America 4 adding six
months of re-shoot which is effectively
a new movie if you look at what they're
doing with allowing Deadpool to be the
only movie next year to give people like
you know time to recalibrate and and
downtime for fans to me it it looks like
phase six is damage control and the
second half of phase five is is
buttoning up as much as you can um it
doesn't to me make sense to keep the
character of Kang
um the way Loki ended allows for that to
be the end of Kang in a way um I do
think it's a bummer for Doom as a
character to not have um the same
impactful opening of taking over the the
big bad because I don't think that would
make sense it also doesn't really make
sense to have the impacts work if you
have a recast Kang be taken out by Doom
because then you're just like we just
met that guy like you're whether or not
you know it's Kang you're still going to
perceive an actor as playing him as a
new actor playing him so you will have
just met him um I also don't think that
they handled you know Kang that well in
Ant-Man so we've had really good Kang in
the periphery uh not everyone watches
Loki everyone that watches the MCU
movies don't watch the show so the one
MCU movie we've had of Kang wasn't the
best debut as is like his his scenes
were great but the movie wasn't in my
opinion so I don't know if Kang does go
on I think that might be why Destin
Daniel keton left I think that you know
he had a plan with as planned MCU and
when that changed he was like all right
let's Avengers 5 you guys do your thing
um I'mma make shangi too sooner now yay
uh I I honestly think that you find a
new way to introduce Doom um you lean on
the impact of the character and uh I I
don't know if i' I'd touch Kang
again yeah cuz the trouble is yeah
majors made Pang like that's the trouble
is like major is so charismatic and so
Talent ented that's what made K I don't
know if the character yeah that's a very
good point cuz cuz yeah people
are so tied to his name and yeah it it
catapulted him into such yeah stardom
certainly past all the buzz that already
existed yeah I'm I'm not sure I don't
think uh sorry I'm also being distracted
by scrolling through stuff um but yeah
uh I think that's a a really solid Point
basically that uh yeah he's he's so
associated with the character now that I
don't think people would be able to not
talk about it if Kang is around at least
for a long time if they bring in a new
Iron Man that gets taken out in one
movie you're not going to suddenly go
like oh I love Iron Man you're going to
go like where's Downey also what
happened oh that fake Iron Man's gone
it'll just feel like a it'll feel
desperate I think yeah we're GNA run
through the rest of these super chats
but we're probably going to wrap things
up in about 15 20 minutes people unless
uh you know unless anything crazy crazy
happens but uh gala ghost Andre good to
see you bud thank you for joining in the
chat hey guys unfortunate news on many
ends but great seeing you both here love
the positive energy you guys bring wish
you happy holidays and cheers thank you
bud appreciate you being here and uh
yeah I wish it was on a a better
circumstance a nicer occasion but it's
always a nice occasion to see your face
so appreciate that Joy being town man
I'm jealous extreme Viper 99 thank you
for chiming in hey Coy John and Greg
just want to say you guys inspire me so
much real rejects have got me through a
hard year love you all thanks for the
laughs Lads absolutely man that means a
lot thank you yeah it's my favorite
content helps me through tough times
times always seem to be tricky so uh so
yeah that means a lot Nate Saunders kind
of disappointed thought he was a great
actor absolutely the the whole thing is
disappointing I'm sad the whole thing
makes me sad I don't know like it's it's
it's sad that any of this had to be the
case whatever the the truth of the
matter is beyond what we know yeah it's
I don't I don't understand anybody who's
like getting Glee out of this situation
but uh extreme Viper 99 thank you for
chiming back in uh also have an amazing
Christmas guys and New Year same to you
same to all of you can't believe that we
are already what day is it today it's
the 18th we got like it's a week till
Christmas man week from
today what do you guys want for
Christmas leave us what you want for
Christmas in the chat King Tut if this
has taught us anything when you are
famous thank you for contributing by the
way stay away from any uh stay away from
them crazy white girls I know Co feel
what I'm saying I don't know about
John I mean I I I love all kinds of
people
man so but I'll be sure to stay away
from white girls from now on although I
don't know what ethnicity is that name
Jabari like you know let's let's let's
dig deeper you know maybe I don't I I
don't know I uh white people of all of
all stripes are are crazy in their in
their
way people are messy and uh I'm a crazy
white girl I that's true I've seen it
that's that's real yeah you know it's
how we do over here Louise
Feliciano uh what if thank you by the
way what if season two is hinting at
Thanos coming back could it be possible
that Thanos returns not just what if but
also the Avengers Disneyland ride has
been hinting at Thanos uh I do think we
get Thanos in uh in secret Wars in some
way um and maybe that's a way to show
the power of Doom right maybe instead of
Doom taking out um Kang it takes out
Thanos easily maybe there's some way to
leverage our you know emotional
connection to how great Thanos was for
you know two act in the second and third
growing into 3x um as a way to make that
impact so that could be um absolutely a
way to do it but I do think we get
Thanos at least a little bit in one of
the secret Wars absolute vodka mck
Pringle thank you for being here once
you pop the fun does not stop especially
with you hey dudes CAD uh glad I could
finally make it to a stream wish it was
under better circumstances you and us
both all three yep do you guys think
recasting or replacement is more likely
thanks for all that y'all do love from
Jersey love to Jersey say what's up to
Miss
Marvel uh yeah I mean we've we've
trotten this territory over the stream a
fair amount
um it seems like just pivoting to a
different character is the most likely
scenario I I just think it's cleaner and
I think uh as I said a few minutes ago
but I think that the amount
of
re retroactive tweaks is already pretty
high so I I don't think they'd want to
you know dig that hole any deeper with
this phase five going into F six I think
they're trying to streamline and clean
up things yeah
absolutely and they've got so many
things to clean up and they have so many
characters we've only seen once one
nerdy perspective thank you so much for
being here and sharing your perspective
I thoroughly enjoy it when koi says what
we all want
to um thanks I appreciate that uh you
voice of the people I just have a lot of
a lot of opinions and uh and you know
you guys help those come out for better
or worse and all the in between Cory M
thank you for being here thank you for
chiming in very glad the victim got jti
as she deserved hope the best for her
absolutely Majors needs to seek help and
hopefully become a better person also
true I mean if again I'm not going to a
continual disclaimer we don't know these
people but I mean I guess the hope is
always that through this difficult and
highly debatable scenario you know
hopefully these people at least have
some cause to look Inward and and yeah I
yeah I grow from the experience I hope
both parties uh find
whatever next phase of their life to be
better than this one because these
people have been in court for months and
obviously dealt with a really toxic
relationship before the trial so I hope
both of them uh find their next chapter
of life so much happier than this one
absolutely and you know I mean it's
about growing and and uh uh what's the
word you know I mean these kinds of
things yes punishments are do out but
you know you also hope that
Rehabilitation or growth is also part of
the process not just like ah damn I'm
bummed that I got punished you know uh
MC no light those 2022 messages are
heavily redacted no context at all given
not denying he was manipulative and
narcissistic but using those messages
when they don't even pertain to this
case is dangerous uh and that's a a
situation in which like I'm I'm looking
forward to the legal eagle video on this
uh or I learned who that was recently
sure that was a good journey for me GRE
Greg told me all about the s s sniper is
that's the right sniper and the legal
yeah and the leg legal of all that yeah
oh boy attorneys at law yeah and and I
mean I don't know I get what you're
saying and I know a lot of people have
brought this up and I know that for this
particular case they were using a fair
amount of character-based evidence to
you know support the idea of whether or
not this person would be capable of
these
actions uh I don't really know enough to
comment on the rules of that alls I know
is it certainly does uh paint a certain
character light um and I could see how
that would be relevant to a situation
like this I can see how you might take
issue with that as well um so I yeah I
don't really have a
solid retort here um you know Fair Point
uh Brandon Jed John and Koy can be the
new Kang variance thank you for your
vote of confidence I think we would do a
great job I think we're what the people
want you know replace this guy with two
white guys two of them and they're like
cat and like we like two halves yeah you
can you can sit on my shoulders and
we'll wear a trench coat the only way
will be as big as Majors big ABS I mean
you know you're getting there you're
getting it's true working on Michelle
thank you for being here and uh and yeah
appreciate hey we're doing our best you
know I'm sure there are more uh
reputable news sites you know for
keeping in the loop with but yeah I
appreciate you being here and I hope
that we're able to at least yeah I don't
know bring some relevant perspective on
this to your day uh straw wild
appreciate you very much for being here
I appreciate the community you've
cultivated thank you I do too I feel
like I mean you know especially in a
live stream you get every kind of
opinion but generally I often feel like
we have a very positive and and a very
upbeat comment section and and just
community in general I like more of
reject Nation than I don't absolute
vodka the good guy uh the da needs to in
uh invest to be inv investigated there's
been too many cases of this nature and
the others are suing for what they've
done in the past that's good to know uh
I mean I'm sure that anybody who has
delivered a verdict is going to you know
try and uh appeal or you know if they
don't feel like they have been served
justce you know try and get some kind of
alternate ruling or whatever um but if
that's the case I mean I would have to
look into this particular district
attorney I don't know much about them
but that's alarming if true Alex Leif
appreciate you being here famous man
breaks up with woman woman then levels
assault accusations against man I wonder
when I've heard this story before did
they break up and then she leveled the
accusations that wasn't my understanding
of this um but I mean I don't know if
you're if you want to view these things
as Petty I guess that's going to be your
choice and uh and I probably will not
dissuade you from it I personally don't
see these kinds of uh
situations as you know the kind you
would want to get into
flippantly uh but I'm glad you
understand Nuance I think it's important
you look at everything as black and
white because that's how the world is
that's a Healthy Outlook and I'm sure
things will go well for
you
always I'm gonna go to the next one yeah
absolutely I was just gonna help I was
gonna give you a second there Aiden
wagland his I am a great man rant is so
arrogant and shows how out of touch he
is
also love the vids and Coy I unabashedly
love your Twitter takes and how you tell
people off when they're bitter about
it uh yeah the the great man rant is is
an interesting one and and I mean cly
didn't bother me nearly as much as it
bothered a lot of people like when he
actually listen to it as opposed to
reading the transcription of it he was I
mean obviously an actor thinking of
himself as Martin Luther King is a bold
statement but the the statement itself
was about him saying he is put in the
Limelight he is someone that is leading
and he is someone that is under a lot of
pressure and as a great man he needs a
great woman and in transcription again
aggressively naive but anyone in the
public eye anyone under a lot of
pressure wants someone supporting them
again I don't think that calling someone
uh Martin Luther King as like a peer is
a logical thing to do but I do
understand saying like hey I am under a
lot of pressure I need someone behind me
uh I just do think that it's a very
manipulative tactic on both parties I'm
under a lot of pressure I'm striving for
greatness and I need someone to
representing people and I and I'm trying
to do my best again I don't know what
led up to that conversation what
happened after that conversation all I'm
saying is that uh the actual rant itself
uh bothered me a bit less but I'm also
arrogant as so I get it um and
thank you uh I I'm trying to for my own
mental health use Twitter less but I
appreciate that and there will be times
I'm at 30k when I want to get to 40K
I'll go on TI raids again and uh for now
though I'm going to try to find peace
which is not happening today absolutely
uh yeah I would have to I I need to hear
the actual uh uh audio I guess I yeah
changes a lot and I and and too even on
the transcript yeah it's it's in the
amalgamation that it becomes Telltale to
me because yeah it's like I get it and
and I understand that a lot of people in
this position have to have a high
opinion of themselves and enough that
they will you know push and see their
you know uh goals through and all that
stuff and build the kind of life that
you know he's trying to build so yeah
like in isolation I don't begrudge that
right um so much Jeff Carroll got a few
from you let's see how far we are okay
we're almost to the end here so I'm
going to close off the super chats and
uh we're going to read the the final few
here and uh and then we will let y'all
get on about your day um let's see real
quick CU we gotta blow everything
up yeah here we go here here we go but
yeah thank you guys for being here and
for the most part being you know
respectful and uh and constructive with
your thoughts and feelings uh we do
appreciate y'all being here and for you
know again if we didn't have uh y'all to
to to to chat to and to bounce all this
stuff off of you know we wouldn't have a
stream at all so appreciate y'all uh for
keeping us on track and uh okay let's
get back to it let's read the the last
of the supers here
we do have a a fair amount more than I
expected today which is nice which is
lovely appreciate y'all again for just
uh being so
supportive uh you know again despite how
kind of icky all of this has been um
let's see okay so we were on Jeff Carol
one of3 MCU is a tough situation that
Kang is so important and so much
groundwork has been laid that it doesn't
seem smart to abandon the character
but they also might feel it safer to
have a clean slate either to avoid cont
controversy not confuse casual fans or
move in a different direction hope for
the best for the MCU if recast my pick
is Lei Stanfield all love unrelated uh
but Percy Jackson in two days can't wait
I've been hearing a lot of great things
about the Percy Jackson TV Disney
streaming series whatever that is and uh
and yeah I think uh you know you're
you're absolutely correct this is going
to be a tough either way this is going
to be tough for Marvel pivoting and
adjusting to this and uh and yeah it
seems like they have put down a lot of
track under the Kang
train but uh yeah I mean certainly to
avoid controversy I got to believe
they're going to have to go in a
different direction because
uh I I think it'll be way too
distracting I personally agree I also
think that the track they put under him
is a bit Rocky uh like yeah there's
track but they also have that post
credit scene that shows all of the
majors as Kang so it's hard to do if
you're considering and all people talk
about postc credit scenes they don't
actually talk about the movie so if the
one of the most important moments being
a post credit scene is the two minutes
where all of them are Majors how do you
have that and then also the messiness of
the storyline and the way Loki ended
allows for it to end so I think I think
it's a good move to to end the Kang Arc
um but I also think um I don't know uh
what was the last thing sorry um uh oh
Lei uh Lei is my brother voodoo man I
think like's energy is is he's got this
mysticism to him like this this
undercurrent of like he's got this
knowledge that like he knows something
and after Haunted Mansion especially I
feel like he'd be such a good brother
Voodoo uh so he that's where he is for
me that's sounds beautiful thank you
Jeff Carroll for chiming in I'll take
any Lei appearance in the MCU or
otherwise the orange pill nurse thank
you for chiming in the same media
Outlets that villainized him and Miss
rep uh resented the facts from the case
variety we'll do an article on this on
his comeback years from now watch
you guys know my thoughts on
variety yeah I and that's only because
they did used to be a trusted Source
like I really like variety um seven
years ago and earlier they're they're
clickbait like anybody else now I mean
if you work on the internet you got to
appeal to the worst of
society that's fair that's why we're
here on a Monday that's what we do
extreme Viper 99 Kang next time
baby and uh he's going to be in armor
Wars now they're going to recast roie
with Jonathan Maj uh Nate felisi thank
you Viper as well uh Hey Co and John
Nate Feliciano thank you for being here
love y'all and all you do how would you
guys feel as John boa as Kang I mean I
love John boa I will take any John boa
in the MCU that I can get I think in the
chat people have said that he has been
shutting that down on social media but
uh I mean if I was treated like that by
Disney I wen't for Disney again yeah
like he literally had a character and
built a Arc and I mean I was shocked
that Oscar Isaac came back he would
never come back in Star Wars I don't
think I mean he even said as much they
uh Perry asked him if he'd ever come
back in the Disney Plus show and he was
like nope so I think he came back for
moonnight because the story worked and
he got to have a little bit more control
but um if I was John boa I wouldn't I
wouldn't work for Disney again nope noop
noop gala ghost thank you for chiming
back in and I will say it here first all
the kangs introduced so far are Scrolls
posing his variant of Kang wink I think
that would be a very
like that we they re-shoot the post
credit scene and then like they use the
frame they use but then just like they
all turn into Scrolls yeah and then Nick
Fury walks out and he's like see I
delivered on my promise found you found
you a place to live and now you just got
to show up dressed as this guy sometimes
Emmanuel Rodriguez the thank you for
chiming in the Jonathan situ uh major
situation is very unfortunate and messed
up Marvel just have to break everything
down and rebuild at this
point uh I don't know they're already in
a position where they need to kind of do
maintenance while driving the car so I
mean there's other stuff I think like
the thing is if they were in a great
place storytelling wise I would be more
concerned but thus far I mean other than
the portent that Jonathan major as Kang
is going to be a significant part of the
next you know two phases these you know
Multiverse Saga
phases uh yeah I mean I feel like they
have it is an unfortunate situation and
and uh I feel like they're already
rebuilding themselves anyway so while
while it's messy I would just yeah yeah
and they've been sitting on this for
months watching this they've had other
problems to deal with um shii D thank
you for being here for chiming in Marvel
really screwed themselves with the qu
media post credit scene and having Kang
play every single variant also I love
watching you guys yeah yeah and I mean
I'm sure
anybody who's not uh you know as plugged
in but but who's stuck around for that
post credit scene will be certainly
maybe taken aack when they never see
this character again but uh yeah we'll
see uh hey Dan v900 thanks for chiming
in appreciate seeing you as well oh and
somebody sent their first Super thank
you so much oh yeah there's been a few
of those KY Clemens is a really is
really good in dope and great in hearts
beat loud in Monarch it's the writing
and directing where she's charismatic
and can sing she's just a bland hacker
and it
stinks this is a random out of nowhere
Dan v900 out of nowhere but thanks for
keeping up with uh I don't know if
you've been keeping up with our Monarch
reactions uh it certainly has felt as
though kiry
Clemens is doing everything she can to
carry the script that they have given
her character those three leads on that
show man like I don't I don't really
blame the actors at all just like the
way they're written it's so Ted R it's
tedious man it's weird like there's a
lot of cool stuff about it's
a people really love the show okay uh
there's fun stuff about it I like
watching it but I do think that it's one
of those shows you watch where you're
sort of taken back by how much people
are like this is great because you're
like because you're like these I and I
and and in the reviews for the episodes
we've bent over backwards to to
basically address that like yeah people
aren't coming to any Godzilla thing or
they typically aren't for you know
character drama but at the Zilla minus
one they can but in the age of Godzilla
minus one they can and also just yeah
looking at this I'm like oh there's so
many other story lines where like the
tone and and everything comes together
in a way that works and uh and this this
beat with kiry like kiry Clemens of the
three present day timeline leads is I
think the best performer like she's
always doing great work but like when
the it's always a matter of when the
script backs her up and only on like
episode seven have I felt that way so
far and kiry is exceptional in dope and
hearts be loud kir is fantastic I got a
lot of love for her so yeah uh thank you
for that uh just a little interstitial
and all 5 Seconds Of The Flash that she
was in yeah Cal ghost I want a Fight
Club reaction for Christmas you I don't
know man you never know it might happen
you just keep your eyes peeled but it
might be just me lurking in the corner
watching him watch it I've seen it so
many times and just being like hey did
you catch that after this we're going to
go fight each other out back what do you
know by yourself you never been in a
fight Bucky bar I mean that's that's a
fair see that's one of those fascinating
movies where I'm like I get how this is
part of the you know easy to
misinterpret starter pack easy to like
if you're idolizing this you maybe got
the wrong message starter pack but at
the same time it's because there are
certain details and philosophies where
you are like well but that in isolation
or that as a jumping off point is fair
it's almost like archb nuanced it you
know much like life I don't think so Co
we should black and white should very
much think this is one or the other
thing nothing in the middle nope never
never uh Nuance smash the like button
says Bucky Barnes ATL give it up for
Bucky Barnes always holding it down
moderating the chat uh smash the like
button like koi smashes the weights look
at that hugging those biceps get after
it you lovelies I can't I'm very excited
for a little time off for gym just just
consum to go to the g go to the gym just
just gains
and can't wait I'm just going to eat and
go to the gym I'm just like it's going
to be I think we I only have like a week
uh I have like six days we're not
scheduled and it's usually like two
weeks but those six days two a days
absolutely very excited love it love
that love you're going to be just like
uh you're just going to be a little tiny
head on just a big old pile of muscles
come back as a cumulus cloud into want
to reemerge I love that cumulus koi
Jason felle happy holidays to you and
your to you too and your family happy
holidays to you and yours as well
appreciate you chiming in thank you for
the support happy uh it is the holiday
season as d as the subject matter of
this stream is it is the holidays and
it's nice to have you all here Maro
Schmidt wiie crazy thank you for uh
chiming in crazy to think that they had
Majors terminated termination papers on
standby oh oh you bet I mean they've had
so many months to draft those up you
know they just had somebody on verdict
Day sitting with a pen and the shredder
you know which way are we going yeah so
dark uh do not envy anyone in this
situation no Marley Morgan thank you for
jumping in I kind of wanted iron lad
well you never know this could still
happen you know maybe they'll do like a
like a little man thing where they CGI
Robert Downey Jr's head onto a tiny body
iron land turns out to be
K but in this version he can't I'm just
letting you know that well Downey's not
coming back either so we're not getting
either iron you never know latty you
never know I don't care how many times
Kevin F like we're not going to mess up
the Iron Man Arc I'm like well what do
you do
now don't do it but uh hey you know who
knows maybe that'll be the way to
introduce Kang later down the line a
bunch bunch later 19 phase 19 iron lad
shows up different face or maybe
Jonathan major is completely changed by
then and he's back who knows pav thank
you for being here greetings from Poland
love you guys absolutely oh my goodness
thank you for tuning in what time is it
in Poland it's got to be at least in the
evening or or middle of the day it's got
to the for us yeah so it's got to be the
evening for you shid D thank you for
joining in uh Co can read our minds love
from South Africa damn Poland and South
Africa in the chat that the Rand is that
a is that those I so I went to South
Africa for for a few weeks uh back in
the day and I still have some I think
they're called Rand the South African
currency uh I stayed in uh Cape Town and
then went out into the desert about 5
hours out of Cape Town for Africa burn
had myself a lovely time at Africa burn
uh but the whiskey and the meat pies and
the
vaccinos uh the Vino is like a it's like
a chocolate coffee smoothie uh is my
like favorite food like Vino at a in
Cape Town much love to South Africa
Boogie also uh it's Marcus Nicholas CES
King Nicholas King uh so but yeah Shi
thank you for yeah for chiming in uh
that's so cool God South Africa Poland
that's awesome uh Dylan Walker thank you
for chining it CH joining joining and
chiming are the two words I tried to say
at the same time will this be another
road situation in terms of seamless
transition Nigeria Australia just giv
giv some love to interrupt but that's
exciting absolutely not bad oh so I
that's one of my favorite things is just
seeing the world the global map of of
viewership and and the reject nation is
Broad you know love feels good Dylan
Walker will this be another Roadie
situation in terms of seamless
transition of characters this one man
was entire Citadel how can we
disconnect yeah that's kind of what I'm
thinking Dylan it's not quite the same I
mean that there's that one great line of
dialogue from uh from Don chenel saying
like I'm here it's me get over it like
just deal with it uh I think he says and
and I thought that was such a genius way
to handle a recasting I don't know if
they can do that with a citadel of one
man playing a character across uh time
in universes it's also conquered time
and I feel like they were trying to make
that him fighting himself the power of
major acting really made that you know a
man versus Man story I honestly don't
see how Kang could be someone else yeah
unfortunately tiari ngoi I hope I uh I
probably butchered your name there I'm
sorry but thank you for being here Jada
pink it his King let's be positive he'll
recover oh
golly you know in in in in an alternate
universe where they're about to release
Scary Movie 6 I'm sure that J is K and
she literally shows up baz Kang and
scary movies and the Press tour would
just be hearing about Tupac I would just
be like all right we get it you uh want
to tell us how close you were to Tupac
and I believe some of this she's still
close to him he's still alive she it's
true he's out in Vegas Elvis is not went
home Ving MC no light thank you for once
again shiming in very generous today
apologies if I came off as Brash being
an AA man in America this just hit me a
bit emotional thank you guys and hope
you both have a great holiday he he uh
afcan americ sure yeah absolutely well
and and and I mean too there is that
like and and I know that certainly
African American men are often subject
to these situations where you're
portrayed as violent or you know
something along those lines and I mean I
guess I can't pretend that there's not
any of that involved in this situation I
I guess I wouldn't be of the mind to
just attribute all of this to that right
now but absolutely like I don't I don't
take issue with people being emotional
over this because it is a bummer it is a
messy situation it does seem kind of it
seems at least a bit tricky to feel like
you have a cut and dried answer and so
at the very
least uh I mean yeah aside from the
people being blatantly disrespectful
yeah like I I can't blame you or take
away from you being emotional about this
and and any kind of heated feelings that
might come from that because it is I
don't know these things also
Force us to look around at systems in
society look at ourselves look at you
know people we know you know they're
very human situations and it does suck
that this uh this character that was so
well played by Jonathan Majors is going
to be either dropped or retooled in
either way that's a mess and and I I I
can't imagine you know the the the
people that are in the chat going like
well yeah when you know an
African-American man calls the cops and
then he's the one that gets in trouble
like that sucks that there's an example
of that whether or not this is Justice
which I don't know uh it does suck
there's another example of that so this
case or the case that's going to happen
in 5 minutes or the time that you know
someone else is assaulted by a cop in
the next 36 seconds is uh is shitty and
uh I'm I'm sorry you have to deal with
that absolutely uh and finally uh thank
you again MC noite seriously and for you
know being patient and and being at
least open to the discourse that we've
had here you know and and not being
flippant um
yeah oh goodness that chat uh anyway
yeah I appreciate you very much and uh
strong with the force closing us out
with a high five appreciate you very
much for the sticker for just showing a
little bit of support and for showing up
in the chat today uh guys this has been
a a fascinating turn of events I'm sure
there will be more you know details or
more discussion and and whatnot and we
have a couple
months or like a month and a half now to
wait until they actually decide what the
verdict will be or not the verdict but
like what the sentencing will be so you
know this isn't over yet but it has yeah
been a a tricky and and difficult topic
of discussion and a and a sad thing to
watch unfold certainly and uh and I
think we all wish we lived on the
timeline where this wasn't the case and
we didn't even have to talk about this
but uh but yeah he has been found guilty
of two counts uh and again the The
Reckless kind not the premeditated kind
which is you know I think note certainly
and uh you know we'll just have to wait
and see what the rest of the MCU shapes
up into because they have officially let
him go it has been officially announced
uh so yeah we'll see that's all I can
say um but yeah thank you guys for being
here thank you for you know showing your
support sounding off letting us know
your opinions and for the most part
being genial and respectful of each
other and of us uh yeah uh goodness
gracious let go do not this let's go do
something else uh Aisha Kenya Walter
chinchilla thank you guys uh for being
here Andres seha uh incredibly goodlook
yug goaler quoting one of my favorite
comedies Zoolander you've seen that but
not Fight Club Brandon P I love I love
Zoolander but I'm just saying just
saying uh though I finally saw nights
stale me yeah oh dude absolutely Bucky
thank you for being a part of our
universe and for holding these chats
down uh very much appreciate you uh
guys just yeah be good to each other be
good people as dead meat would say if we
don't see you uh before then in live
because we probably won't be saying on
every you know filmed and edited video
have a great holiday whatever you
celebrate whatever you don't celebrate
if you don't celebrate anything enjoy
the time off if you celebrate everything
enjoy all that booze uh and if you're
sober enjoy all that time with your
family and if your family's not here
enjoy the found family you've made and
have and if you don't particularly like
people enjoy the quiet uh but I I hope
you have a good downtime and I'm very
much looking forward to it myself uh I'm
I'm especially aggravated that this is
the time that people think I'm chilling
for Marvel when I couldn't be matter at
them sending us screeners on the
holidays and uh yeah I'm not thrilled
about any of this happening but um we
hope that we at least informed some of
the more uh complicated details of the
situation and um if you are someone who
is in a horrible envir M and
um the this case notwithstanding whether
or not you believe this case went the
right way or the wrong way if you're in
a relationship that's unhealthy and
um you should feel safe hopefully can
find a way safely to get out of it and I
don't want people villainizing um this
man or this woman to affect how you
perceive men or women of of any ill and
and uh how you perceive the judicial
process how you perceive how you are are
being treated in life so if you're not
being treated well um get out of that
situation however you can safely and uh
if you are the type of person that was
leaving the comments that we were
dealing with therapy because you're
probably treating other people as shitty
as as you are treating us so just you
know take care of yourselves uh love one
another and have a great holiday I
appreciate most of you very much yep
absolutely thanks guys be well and we'll
catch you on the next one cheers